[Music]
in December of 2015
Ubisoft Montreal released Rainbow six
siege it was met with positive critical
praise and accrued a following of
dedicated players but for whatever
reason be it unstable servers a lack of
game modes or a general waning interest
in the Rainbow six brand siege
underperformed it quickly faded from the
wider video game conversation but what
happened next has become common
knowledge Rainbow six siege became one
of the most prominent comeback stories
in modern video games six months after
release it had reached 10 million
players one year after that it had
crossed 20 million and as of now as
you're watching this video Rainbow six
siege has more than 27 million players
if early sales estimates were accurate
then Ubisoft tactical shooter has
increased its player base by about 900
percent in only two years some credit
this meteoric rise to the games tactical
possibilities which seem to multiply the
more you play it others cite Ubisoft's
attention to its community and its
transparency with patches maintenance
and improvements but most would agree
it's the free dlc that has spurred all
of this momentum the updates are broken
into four seasons each year with new
maps modes and of course operators these
are the lifeblood of Rainbow six siege
they add variables and layers to every
match there the characters that people
learn practice with and grow attached to
they add personality to a game that
could otherwise be a macho looking
military shooter in the weeks prior to
each Rainbow six update it's the new
operators that fans fixate on scouring
for leaks that might reveal each heroes
unique abilities or character traits and
to hear Ubisoft tell it operators are
the central pillar of sieges design so
we travel to Montreal during the Rainbow
Six Invitational to talk to the
developers about the introduction of new
operators and how they lend more life to
Rainbow six siege
[Music]
I come from my first school in terms of
game plays shooter
you know since do ma'am shut up player
but admire on my road I discovered also
dat s you know we sacre couer aft Exeter
and also the MOBA game like dota
excetera and on a side I was extremely
skill based another society was kind of
brain based and as soon as I had the
right to do what I want on this project
I merged both world in fps in the
nominate path the stars of the 80's of
the weapon in number 60 okay you're
shooting sure but you're not doing only
that you're using ability you're using
power using strategy so then it makes
the character standing out you know a
bit like more and fighting again or
stuff like that with the game overall
what you're trying to do is build a game
that can sustain the time that that in
10 years you will still be playing that
game those operators obviously having
evolved having change having learn new
play styles but that's pretty much what
we are envisioning by definition the
game is a sandbox that's why we took the
decision to have destruction destruction
it's about potential okay it's like
Santa okay and on the other side you
have to your Protoss operators are tools
to play with the Sun and it come from
this vision what you will bring into the
game you as a player and it's called
creation and this has no limit we were
surprised for those last two year on how
much the community you know took our
corporate took our universe and you know
like Mexico story when the game was
launched and moving forward we started
to see people picking on individuals and
over the cost of the past year that's
how we started to approach the creation
of new characters like they are not a
unit org
anymore that essentially an individual
so how do you make a military guy a guy
or girl stand out as an individual so
that's really the challenge and it
started ended with a to drum up Raiders
aliens of here injecting a much more
backstory
much more even relationship between
those characters that are obviously not
gameplay but purely narration and moving
forward I think that's really the
ambition to build up those characters
backstory interaction between them why
not love stories between the different
ones existing and new I think that's the
ground that we are gonna start
investigate soon and don't forget one
thing if you remember but they did it in
a different way
the first Rainbow six the first first
one had operators ding chavez you know a
long list of land operators with
different skill it was not developed
like what we are doing right now because
it's absolutely unique in terms of
development characterization but they
were already on this kind of approach
when we are working on an operator's we
are building a story a backstory a poet
specific ability and also a list of who
are the friends of this operator who are
the enemies of the operators but it's
never enough a part of the real game
will come directly from what player
invented for instance the body trick I
don't know if you know the Bundy trick
we never imagined such a mechanic never
never in design we had an idea about
someone trying to destroy the breaching
charge just by placing it quickly and
it's purely community driven because you
were already creating imagining
something it's this is a good mind we're
looking for you know we don't want to
write everything we are playing as
materials first we know you know our
player think and me when I want to when
I want to bring myself to a game I want
to bring also my creativity I want to
create something I want to think about
the game I don't want to think about the
meta not only what I'm playing but also
when I'm walking into the street excites
has to be part of my mind
in an interview with PC gamer last year
Remy famously said the team is aiming
for a total of 100 operators over the
next 10 years because of this roadmap
Ubisoft also said it has no plans for a
sequel siege is doing so well that
they're only focused is supporting it as
a service in the years to come and why
wouldn't they sieges post release
explosion is nothing short of
astonishing and its numbers are only
growing and with this influx of players
comes a new set of problems how do you
maintain the health of your game while
also continuing to grow how do you
balance a roster that might eventually
rival that of dota 2 and how do you
create so many powerful characters that
still feel somewhat rooted in real life
I thought Mia would be the first example
you know I'm really at that time I was
like okay maybe this is a limit that we
can go like making a wall invisible I
mean like it's too much doesn't it
doesn't connect to military stuff but we
have insane and awesome people that
always manage to find a twist underway
and it's cool because in a way I've been
good you know having like to be always
bonded it's also like some things that
forced you to be innovative and to sing
differently because you still want to
have the same kind of gameplay but you
can't do it like with the usual like
super technical joystick or magical
where they are without explain
or had eyes on us I always feel like
having wood is better than not having
woods you know having constraints in
terms of design is always better at
having no constraint we never want to
predict the meter before the players
okay the meta is named and defined by
what's happening between the this
encounter between the developers ID and
the way the player will play the content
so to me I consider the game as a bridge
between Hearst developers and the
community and the result it's called the
meta we are approaching it with the
where where what are the new territories
of gameplay that we haven't yet done
we've done obviously a gadget or than
several the preachers we've done several
families of designer and with the past
season which were more the intelligence
and the observation phase this season
with Lionel finca is essentially gonna
be about the Global's meaning like
abilities that are across the map and
across all of the players within that
map
changing our ranks
[Music]
so it's how do you conquer New
Territories in terms of gameplay keeping
in mind that our ambition is one day to
other 100 operators so lion when we are
working on Lion Z idea right now it's
really like Intel it's a big part of
this game and we want you to create an
operator that give a more accessible way
to get Intel but still open for country
of life for the defending team but on
the opposite as you mention when we
every time we pitch an operator with a
designer come and Kitchener Parham the
design document we have a we have a
specific space in the template that is
color punch or play and for example lion
scream job I neutrino if you put a new
gem around to create an area where you
can freely move and there is no signal
that is sent back to the board
then comes the notion of who are those
two nationalities who are those two
characters what is their backstory how
are they linked to the rest of the lore
what is their interaction between each
other what can we tell about them kuvira
for instance a cool character a
character we want to maybe find an Intel
but but through an interrogation you see
so often now we are also inspired by
what kind of character is behind it's
not only main game mechanics now we also
inspired by just personality and it's
something we want to bring in the game
we want to add many faces you know many
personality coming from the lot of
nation with different colors different
it's something extremely important for
us that's something that constantly came
up in my chats with sieges creators
diversity not only its importance to the
game's roster but also its player base
Rainbow six is growing and as new
operators come to the game morph the
meta and gain their own dedicated fans
siege will continue to reach new parts
of the world it may have realistic
trappings and a military aesthetic but
Ubisoft this proud of the colorful
universe it's creating siege has become
one of the most played games today
alongside overwatch dota 2 fortnight and
player unknowns battlegrounds largely
because of its vibrant cast and
dedicated community and as siege moves
into its third year it's showing no
signs of slowing down
just in terms of game development you
want to have the maximum people playing
your game so the more you represent them
the mother is a chance for them to pay
again so yes the more diverse we are the
better it will be for the community and
for the games well I mean like at the
end in the next 10 or 20 year we want to
have done every country that our city
you units because it's all about
diversity and you people you should
select how people are super happy when
we are going into that country it's
insane the amount of love will receive
and so there is no reason for us to not
do every country in the world because
everyone's developed
[Music]
you